during uh the break before troy aikman
the big trade in the nba has in fact hit
um james harden is in fact a
philadelphia 76er and ben simmons and
seth curry and andre drummond and two
first-rounders
going to brooklyn
so they can bring james harden and paul
millsap
from the brooklyn nets and we figured to
help break it down uh is uh the the
nearest beard we could find
um and he just happens to be our next
guest who got here nice and early he is
a pro football hall of famer charles
woodson
how are you rich i'm doing well man how
are you i'm great what do you what do
you think of the trade what are you
demonstrating you know i think it's
awesome because you know a lot of times
you get to the trade deadline and
nothing happens right now you kind of
let down right so this is this is great
i think it's great for
uh us as fans but then in terms of the
teams yeah yeah you know i think this is
a this is a great trade for the brooklyn
nest if you can get something out of ben
simmons because we really don't know
what's going on with ben simmons
we don't like is he was he hurt
is it mental
so is he going to all of a sudden
come into the gym and just start running
the show like how's this thing gonna
work but in terms of what it adds to
that team
uh a big point guard long
great on the defensive end of the floor
um you don't have to worry about him
shooting the ball like he wouldn't do
right
because you got guys for that kyrie
irving
and uh you know kevin durant those are
the guys that you want with volume shots
and then i think to me i think the
biggest piece of this is seth curry
you look at the uh the series last year
against um the bucks
we all expected that joe thomas would be
the guy that he's gonna be open he's
gonna drain shots he couldn't hit a shot
and all of a sudden this game goes to
seven they can't pull out a win seth
curry is going to be able to make shots
right so i think in terms of the
brooklyn nets i think this was a great
trade for this yeah you could in and uh
harris is out for the season right yeah
joe harris is out for a while on that
mental uh health point charles ramona
shelburne just tweeted as well that
simmons is going to continue to work
with his therapist to get mentally ready
to play quote it's a work in progress
uh he's thrilled with the change of
scenery and has already spoken to kevin
durant
but can't but can he can he work while
he's getting mental health and
see that's and that this is a very
thorny subject as you know and we all
know and you know calvin ridley missed
much of the season you know um
uh and um lane johnson missed some games
in philadelphia just on the nfl front
this year our friend jay glazer has
written a terrific book on the subject
matter of getting rid of the gray and
trying to have blue sky days and and
it's a very severe subject matter and
we're back here on the rich eisen show
terrestrial radio outfit charles woodson
is here chopping up the trade of uh
james harden um to philadelphia and ben
simmons and seth curry and andre
drummond and pix going to brooklyn but
you know
if all of a sudden simmons shows up like
hey i'm ready to play basketball it's
like well what was the mental health
about ben you know and so
uh
the first reaction that he's still
working with a therapist it's i'll be
honest with you i'm i'm kind of pleased
to hear that because the last thing i
want to do is have anybody ever look at
somebody and saying what what's that
mental health about yeah but then
if you come back and you're inserted
right into the lineup how do you explain
it exactly you can't you can that's th
that's the thing like we we we're all
sympathetic i don't know what he's going
through you know the two things you
don't know it's what's going on in a
man's head and what's going on in this
in this house right
but if you come back and immediately
you're playing
you got to kind of explain
what was going on for the first half of
the season
why couldn't you come back and play like
that
that's that's the great area great area
that we're dealing with right now yes
and everyone was just assuming it it was
whatever was going on in philadelphia
and that might might have might have led
to it and now he's going to new york
which you know is not for the
it world not but the good thing is that
we're you know whereas in philadelphia
at times it's like he's got to be the
one to make the shots
now he doesn't now he can actually fill
the role and he was you know he's an
extremely talented kid
did you point out it could be seth curry
that could be the key to this deal too
well and then on the flip side um
he wasn't taking shots in philly
but now you get a guy
who takes some shots you know he wasn't
as dominant in brooklyn as he was in
houston
uh and it stopped before that but james
harden is a guy that he can take over a
game
and i just think that's what they're
looking for in that position from
offensive side now he's not going to
give you that same defense that ben
simmons will give you but offensively
you pair a guy up with embiid who is
by all accounts you know from what i
hear and what i watch he's like he's the
mvp of the league that's what we were
talking about here on this show right tj
he's the mvp of the freaking seven years
he's not the lead right right i know
with no help so he's unstoppable and
seth curry is uh no longer on uh doc
rivers team huh chris
and he might and thanksgiving is going
to be longer on the christmas
gonna be wishes
awkward for free
is dox son-in-law
but doc's already traded his actual own
son yeah so in fact in los angeles
seth should have seen this coming
because doc has traded his own his son
doc has now been part of a trade of his
son and son-in-law
does he have anybody else that he could
do nothing is sacred i don't know that's
a heck of a thanksgiving table right
could you imagine all of them together
today and all of a sudden this comes
across the ticker
and everybody's looking at each other
like
[Music]
[Applause]
you did this to me
how dare maury must be out of his mind
excited right now
feels like it looks like they could have
just cut out the brooklyn middle man
last year right
am i wrong because he didn't want to
trade ben simmons at the time well i
mean it may not have been him
could have been somebody else but he
held out he held he stood pat the entire
time yeah
now hey look now it's also on harden
yeah right
it's now this is like how many more
times has this man been acquired by a
team can a man be acquired by a team by
saying missing piece championship and
then
not at all right right and then
basically force your way out
to another team right you know but once
you get there what are you going to do
well at least he didn't eat his way out
of this one right
i did say that you did you did
i did say that
we think that he was just layered up for
that one
but it just looked like he was what are
you talking about remember that picture
before he got traded to brooklyn it
looked like he put on about 30 and then
like three days later it was like wait a
second it's gone all the way are you
saying are you are you cool tj jefferson
chris brockman by the way two-thirds of
the rich eisenhower basketball podcast
were all possible we talked to all about
this you're welcome welcome to be a
guest you were saying to charles woodson
here that you believe at one point james
harden was so
wanting out of houston he put on an
actual fat suit for a game and played an
effect
is that what you're saying oh not the
facts i think he's not ruling it out
like a nutty professor
so charles you believe that this you
said how you feel this trick this trade
is going to affect the nets what about
the sixers what are you
how do you
yeah that's what i was saying i you know
i think with hardin um
you know we always talk about having you
know a big three
but i think in terms of harden and
embiid together like that's enough
you know of a duo
you know to really cause damage if you
get the harden
that will go and take over a game
because we really hadn't seen
you know the harden you know that we
used to see prior to going to brooklyn
like really taking over games and then
you know with him i mean
got the hamstring you know he forced his
way out right but so is he healthy
is he going to be able to play dinosaurs
we just established he's a man who
looked fat one day and then was an
all-star that's not good for your
hammies he's no hot chocolate
you know
has there ever been a team
that averages on a nightly basis
a third to maybe 40 percent of their
points from the free-throw line
because between embiid and harden now
yeah are there two guys who get to the
line more in the nba than these two guys
i mean nb embiid likes
over his stretch in january he averaged
like 15 20 made free throws a night yeah
that's because i guess everything was
going through him and he's playing
orlando and it was no offense because i
know that's you know your neck of the
woods but um you know
i i i can't wait to see it
and if the basketball gods smile upon us
first-round match-up
sixers and nets if there is a way that
we can make this happen first round now
i don't know the nets won't fall into
the to the to the point right now nets
won't fall in the plan and then the nets
get in the plane and wind up
you know and and the heat or the one
seed so it's not like you know the
sixers are guaranteed to be the one yeah
the top six teams in the east decided by
four games separate from brooklyn
currently eighth did go why not brooklyn
is at eight now yeah so why can't i mean
there's only five games separating one
from them
so so it all gets ordered
lost right so brooklyn gets its act
together let's just say maybe gets up to
the sixth seed and uh the sixers based
on all the ordering wind up in the three
seed three versus six here we go 76ers
right off the bat though
first round oh pieces i like my steak
served first up
76ers started the day 13-1 win the title
now seven to one i want to paired with
paired with the intercept wine that's
why i'm like
why what a lovely plug the tougher the
opponent the more you need a game plan
by on tech and pfizer remind you to
consider getting vaccinated against
covet 19. so uh hour number three your
conversation with uh we are expected to
have you we appreciate you sitting down
nice and early and dak prescott in
studio hour number three that's the way
we're rolling here on the rich eisen
show still here on peacock though for
another couple of minutes um all right
this is this is
this is wild
i'm not used to talking basketball
during an nba
during a super bowl week no but i'm also
not used to parenting during a super
bowl week either because i'm home
all-star dad that's what i am i'm a pro
bowl dad
do you think we should change the pro
bowl rules what do you think
what do you think uh
yeah you do yeah i think
you know
it's a vacation you know for guys yeah
um
you know you can do you know whatever
competition drills you want to
and let the guys come bring their
families have a good time have things
set up for them to do but the actual
game
you know guys now man are
protective of their brand
they're they're very smart they're
protective of their bodies and nobody's
going out there trying to go full bore
and hit anybody they're just not going
to do it anymore so there's no way
you're going to be able to bring that
back
that is gone that train has
left the station
and
you can hear the guys coming out now you
know the tweets some of the tweets
you've seen it's like man why would we
do that you know so
change it just get rid of the game i get
rid of the game do some type of skills
competition you know um you know they
throw the ball hitting targets maybe you
do really the fastest man contest like a
legitimate one where tyrique actually
runs right you know
uh something to that effect um you know
of course do some things in the
community with charity and those those
sorts of things but
the actual game if you want to do a 707
like some type of flag do that but
they're hitting they're not going to do
it
i got a minute left here did you ever
lay someone out in the pro bowl
absolutely not you never did that i
didn't want to hit nobody either
so to me i play on the outside so it's
really for the for the dbs and the wide
receivers it's a skilled competition
with us like you're you're guarding the
guy you want to let him know hey man i'm
the best at what i do you think you're
the best at what you do but
once you get into the interior yeah
where things get tight
you know there's only a rare you know
there's a couple of guys you know sean
taylor was famous for his hit on the
kicker you got a few guys that don't
mind they'll just go whatever but but
for the most part it's not happening the
doc you and brady did with nfl films on
espn about the talk rule is one of the
best football documentaries i've ever
seen it is that good
well not only because it's so well done
nfl films doing their thing but it's
it's
it's you
sitting down with tom brady going over
one of the most famous plays in the
history of the nfl playoffs
and it's real talk between the two of
you guys yeah right like
it was and it's funny because over the
years i've had so many people that have
walked up to me and said hey man have
you and tom ever talked about that play
and it's like no like really why why
would we you know the play happened it's
not as if
tom made the call
he's just part of the play so there's
really no reason to talk to him and be
like hey tom man
you made the wrong call he didn't make
it
uh but as time went on you know we both
got approached you know nfl films let's
talk about the the play
and uh he was in i was in and we sat
down man and we just we had a lot of fun
you know talking about it but what i
will say is
i tweeted this the other day is that i'm
i'm not a lawyer
but i do have my doctorate of laws from
the university of michigan yes
i won the case
hey
you guys watched it
did you hear him
oh fumble that's right it kind of
slipped out of him but wrong guy
that was the truth spilling out of him
so again your position is even with the
rule being what it was you still think
it's a fumble or or what because the
rule at the time
made it clear that if you are bringing
the ball down in the process of bringing
it down and the ball comes loose that's
considered an incomplete pass which is
absurd
because as i was saying for years
and mike pereira the head of nfl reps at
the time was countering that it removes
the gray area
from whether it's a pass or not i'm like
actually you're creating the gray area
right that there's no more
of a clear indication i do not intend to
throw than by tucking the football that
so the immediate process of tucking
makes you a runner and that should be a
fumble 100 that's it end of story and
this entire documentary is the gray area
and two greats involved in an all-time
play
um
is just you're arguing gray area and i'm
just thinking to myself my kids when
they grow up and see this stuff they'll
be like wait a minute what are you
talking about exactly
like what are you talking about and the
way they always start the argument is
that his arm was going forward
well at which point his arm's not going
forward
it's no longer a pass or an attempt to
pass
if you're attempting to tuck the ball
back under if you know even if you're an
attempt yeah even if you don't get it
all the way back to the body and like
like i explained in a documentary i said
tom once you got the ball here
you've never thrown the ball downfield
down here right you're bringing that
ball back
it doesn't matter what happened
beforehand
it's a fumble like that just is what it
is and so everybody oh well that was the
rule and you know yeah maybe it was a
fumble but that was the rule
dude i don't care about a rule
[Laughter]
to be broken
there's no argument for
bringing the ball back slapping it out
fumble it's over but then you guys are
like going at it about did you know tom
talk brought it didn't it never hit his
second hand
you know and if he had touched his
second hand then obviously now he
becomes a runner and he wouldn't have
been able to get out so he made up his
own rule
so
if you're both of your hands touch
the ball that constitutes as a fumble
so when it was all over in the day the
shoot was over how did it end between
the two of you you know uh you know i
gave him a bottle of whiskey and
he was on his way i was on my way
that was it what did you think when tom
walked out and he was wearing the super
bowl ring from that year
hey
just right in the face you know like a
little knife in the gut you know it's
like man
it's like the song that's supposed to be
me
did you know he was bringing a super
bowl ring that day did you know that uh
no i i did that
and
you do you know how many people think it
was brady's house that you shot this in
it was not his house correct that you
shot this in oh it was not it was not i
think we saved him though because that
was this house you'd probably have
people riding by spray paint tuck rule
on this house
we don't want we don't want that
we don't want that rich who won the pool
game did brady end up beating you i got
crushed oh yeah yeah i was caught up in
the moment you know
yeah he was in your head
what would happen if it went the other
way and i'm trying to shoot yeah he got
me well the two parts of this
documentary that really like one i
didn't know well all of them i didn't i
didn't realize and one i didn't know the
one i didn't know is eric allen your
teammate
and the play before
the tuck
um and the play before
he brady's running out of bounds and
eric allen saw charlie weiss the oc go
up to tom and basically
you know have an opportunity with his
young quarterback to physically face to
face tell him what we're going to do
next yeah and eric hid behind the
and heard
what the next play call was going to be
so just
kind of just inconspicuously he's
standing on their sideline and so what's
interesting is that when he came to the
huddle
he was like explaining what they were
going to do right but
we were like
how do you know that right
hey this is what the team's going to do
and yeah we're like really okay so
the way they lined up
it was set up for that because it was
three by one single receiver side and
it's like
damn
he's gonna try to throw it ea's gonna
pick it
and so that was that's the thing that
gave me time to get there and that's
what made him bring the ball back down
that's what caused the fumble so he
brings the ball back down because he
sees if i let it go it's a pitcher
and but the fact that he saw that and
that option was taken away immediately
allowed you the time to get to him
that's it
and he's so so he told this to you in
the huddle and you called that that that
defense specifically based on his
information no no we we uh
the play they called the play it was a
blitz on
and uh so for me lining up the way i did
i tried to line up as wide as i could
you know just to make it seem like i'm
lined up over the receiver i have the
receiver as man-to-man to just kind of
get out of his his purview
and uh play snap i'm coming from out
wide
so
he you know brings the ball back down
i'm there i got time to get there
because ea's sitting there waiting
for this ball to release out of his hand
so if he throws the ball ea's going
60 yards the other way
and the other thing i didn't realize is
you hit him in the head
and then
brady when the ball was out he came
he kicked him right in the right
he who do you trip he treats him with
baker he tripped beaker trying to go
recover yeah who ended up recovering
right he recovered it actually got it
yeah yeah and so so basically it's two
to one
what's the other one what's the
what are you saying yeah i mean it
really was well done
it was it was a lot of fun
and it was great yeah so i wasn't
expecting some of the names to pop i
mean walt coleman the actual referee
from the game in the documentary he was
great there's no intent in the rule i'm
so thankful this thing's out of the
rulebook it's just such a dumb
conversation just a dumb conversation
was he bringing it down was he not
that's the act of going from here
doing this regardless if it's forward or
not right is a clear indication i no
longer intend to throw and that's what i
was telling pereira for all those years
and guess what happened they took the
rule out you're welcome
you know what rich you're welcome thank
you i'm a factor that's all i'm trying
to say you're a force you're right i'm a
force
with which to be reckoned that's right
um okay let's uh talk about uh what's
the knock on the door ford hall of fame
fans that you're gonna be part of right
here uh fans have a chance to be repped
in the hall of fame in the hall of fame
man just like all of the legends of the
game okay they'll have a display in
canton
and every year you have fans that are
nominated
and uh you know what they're they get a
knock
from you somebody gets a knock you and
you're and you do that you get a knock
i'll let you know hey
you're in the ford hall of fans wow how
cool is that for the fans there you go
that's awesome you get the knock yeah
and then the uh at the uh porsche
experience center in carson california
you uh your founding partner of the
annual culinary kickoff that's going
down tonight going down tonight yeah
that's always a great event the food is
amazing the the uh the wine that you
pour is amazing great great wine and
food experience um
raises a lot of money for culinary
students
uh michael mina charlie palmer who are
the headline chefs they always bring in
local chefs whatever city where city
that we're in
uh chrissy delillo from the delilah
group you know puts this she started
this years ago her marshall falk
and uh i was kind of you know brought in
you know to tag along somebody needed we
needed the wine charles got it you got
to bring some wine got to bring the
great wine man a little little intercept
wine now um so it's a great event it's
been going on the last eight years and
uh it's one of the best events i think
that i attend during super bowl week and
it's awesome and yeah you know whenever
i can make it that uh i love being there
and it's a great event um who do you
think wins this game what do you got for
me on sunday uh
i like the rams why i like the rams
i like the rams really for for because
of one player
i just got i just have the utmost
respect 99 or 5's 99 okay 99 is
when you look at this bengals team and
the thing that they struggle with of
course it's
defensive line play being able to get to
him we know what happened in tennessee
they were able to get to him a bunch of
times
but aaron donald is just a different
deal he can take this game over and i
think that if he can get to joe burrow
multiple times which i think that he
will
i think that'll be the thing that'll get
to
joe barrow like i think that that magic
will run out in terms of taking the
beating that he's taking
and continuing to just make plays uh
down the field then of course the rest
of the guys along with them you know
leonard floyd
von miller has
played lights out in the playoffs jalen
and those guys and how about eric weddle
a veteran in the backfield how amazing
is that going from the couch to this
amazing
couch to the super bowl and actually
getting minutes
like we all thought maybe he'd get you
know 10 15 plays no he's playing the
whole game he won't be taking off yeah
like no no so i like it because of the
defensive side of the ball and in
particular aaron donald and what i think
the the disruption they'll cause on that
offense yeah the sense is he's going to
hit borough uh so many times one of his
nines is going to wind up next to one of
burrows wow
that's the general side of this thing
right now do you like that one i would
like that take it
[Music]
that's the idea for that sort of thing
but um and then odell what he's doing
too yeah for the rams yeah happy for
odell happy for matthew stafford
and i've played you know against matthew
stafford always had a lot of respect for
him he's a tough quarterback um gifted
you know arm throwing wise and
you know what you come out of you know
detroit detroit's had two of the
all-time greats
that left
the team early after 10 years calvin
johnson barry sanders
so it's not
it wasn't all on matthew stafford like
they have some other things
organizationally right they have to you
know fix and write and here he comes
into the rams
his first year there there in the super
bowl because he is a good quarterback
and then odell he's just proven that
he's still one of the best receivers in
the game you know he's taking a hit you
know in terms of media wise what he is
and what he isn't
but this guy is a world-class you know
wide receiver and if he gets the
match-ups
they're paying attention to cooper cup
and he's on the outside by itself they
don't have anybody on the outside
that can play with odell i don't believe
so
put all the attention on cup o'dell
should have
a good game okay before i let you go
what what happened at michigan in the
last month what happened do we know uh
you know i have no idea what happened
but it was the weirdest week of football
that
i've ever witnessed at michigan you know
the coaches interviewing
national signing day or whatever
goes to interview for another job
he comes back nope
i'm never looking at the nfl again i
want to coach michigan and then the
offensive coordinator leaves
and then he writes a nasty little letter
i'm not respected here and he's going to
miami for the same position it's like
what are we doing
you know so i'm
i'm clueless to how that all worked out
but
you know what still had a good class of
recruits seems like it yeah so
you just got to bring guys in and know
how to coach them yeah i know and if
there's anybody who could put this
toothpaste the you know the the amazing
blue toothpaste back in the tube it's
it's our guy jim harbaugh that's that i
believe but um you know i i imagine he's
going to deal with at least a year or
two
of coaches who are you know coming next
in the living room saying who was just
here is that the guy who
you know went and talked to minnesota
right
we're not doing that right even though
they might then turn around the next day
and actually do that you know what i'm
saying but well i think he tried to
clear it up by saying you know what i'm
done
looking at the nfl so now you know you
go into right no appearance or the kid's
home you're saying
i'm done with the nfl i'm going to be
here for your son
so let's hope that's the truth how great
would it be if they beat ohio state
again next year like because you know
all ohio state fans you must see them
all the time you must know them you must
run into them you must hear from them
they all think last year was a fluke
oh yeah jim just screwed it all up
because he went and talked and just lost
these coordinators and we're all in
disarray
go back in there and horseshoe and do it
for a second straight time uh honestly i
don't i don't i don't know how they
would be able to handle that
well i know how i would be able to
[Laughter]
i was living my best life here honestly
it felt good didn't you oh god you have
no idea how much trash this guy was oh
it was great so the entire show i've
been the entire show charles
there was a rich eisen who had never
existed before rich who had his own tv
show and had michigan beat ohio state
and had ohio state become a basketball
school
yeah because they beat duke you know in
basketball the buckeyes three days later
i congratulated them on being a
basketball school
that's great notre dame notre dame's guy
left notre dame is clearly a stepping
stone job i was just oh oh god it was
the best retirement
oh
that's great i mean when you have your
time to shine man you got to let it
thank you you gotta let it go charles he
was saying that with his chest for like
a month straight of mine
charles woodson here on the rich eisen
show great to see you intercept wines
dot com is that where you can go to this
cw intercept wine.com very good for and
for your your woodson whiskey.com there
you go
oh this man you know exactly how to roll
at charles woodson on twitter and
instagram as well right here on the rich
eisen show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here